goûter pour moi ça change strictement
rien ce que je faisais avant parce que
je travaillais qu'à 15 heures par jour
je suis moins d'un mois devant mon
ordinateur je sortais une demi-heure une
heure faire d'exercice et je vais de
temps en temps faire des courses neuf
jurés je concentre les courses sur une
durée plus courte en faisant plus
attention et le reste c'est exactement
pareil j'espère simplement on va pas
m'empêcher de venir ici pour être
honnête je fais ce que je fais
d'habitude je vais courir je fais un peu
d'exercice même si mes amis ne doivent
pas aller dehors je peux m'occuper tout
seul vous savez pour être honnête
la police est vraiment rude dans sa
façon de faire il faut qu'elles
aboutissent
un peu ses manières quand je marche et
je les croise je leur dis bonjour en
souriant et ils me disent un peu énervé
où sont vos papiers est vraiment très
près de chez moi pour faire les courses
là je me suis un peu aventuré à trois
pâtés de maisons pour courir le matin
parce que voilà un bien fou sinon je
pense que ceux qui ont des terrasses et
mais est ce que je ne comprends pas
c'est que j'ai des messages de gens de
là qui y habitent à la campagne qui nous
disent mais faites gaffe joué le jeu ce
qu'on fait mais eux sont la campagne en
train de faire leur barbecue sur
tranquille donc c'est un petit peu
injuste voilà